>> Tucker: EVERY DAY CHINA
MOVES CLOSER TO OVERTAKING
THE UNITED STATES.
JUST BECAUSE THEY ARE
GETTING STRONGER
ECONOMICALLY DOESN'T MEAN
THE CHINESE PEOPLE ARE MORE
FREE.
THEY ARE NOT.
CHINA IS STILL IMPRISONING
MUSLIM POPULATION IN THE
WEST.
ORDINARY CHINESE STILL LOSE
ACCESS TO TRAVEL OR
EDUCATION IF THE GOVERNMENT
SAYS THEY HAVE POOR SOCIAL
CREDIT.
AND NOW A HACKER HAS
DISCOVERED A BIZARRE CHINESE
DATABASE THAT EVALUATED
MILLIONS OF CHINESE WOMEN ON
WHETHER THEY WERE QUOTE
BREED READY AUTHOR OF THE
COMING CLASP OF CHINA CAN'T
COME TOO SOON.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
GORDON, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WHAT DOES BREATHE READY MEAN
AND WHY WOULD THEY BE
ASSESSING THAT.
>> BREED READY MEANS THEY
ARE ABLE TO BREED CHILDREN.
THE REASON WHY IS CHINA HAS
DECLINING ITEM MOCKOGRAPHY.
IF YOU START TO LOOK AT SOME
OF THE STATISTICS THEY ARE
REALLY FRIGHTENING.
LAST YEAR THEIR BIRTH RATE
FELL ABOUT 12%.
PERHAPS TO THE LOWEST RATE
IN THE HISTORY OF THE
PEOPLE'S REPUBLIC GOING BACK
TO 1949.
WE ARE SEEING THAT THE
WORKFORCE HAS ALREADY TOPPED
OUT.
THE POPULATION AS A WHOLE
WILL TOP OUT SOON.
CHINA'S OFFICIALS ARE JUST
IN A PANIC.
>> Tucker: SO THEY ARE
IDENTIFYING WOMEN WHO ARE
BREED-READY BUT THEN WHAT DO
THEY DO WITH THAT
INFORMATION?
IS THERE GOING TO BE A
CO-HERRIVE BREEDING PROGRAM
IN CHINA?
>> THERE POSSIBLY VERY
POSSIBLY COULD BE.
SOME CHINESE OFFICIALS ARE
NOW TALKING ABOUT HAVING A
TWO CHILD POLICY WHICH IS
NOT A MAXIMUM TWO CHILDREN
BUT THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
REQUIRING COUPLES TO HAVE
TWO CHILDREN.
NOW, OF COURSE, CHINA IS NOT
THERE YET.
BUT YOU CAN SEE WHERE THEY
ARE GOING.
LARGELY BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BEEN TAKEN BY SURPRISE BY
COLLAPSING DEMOGRAPHY.
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN WARNING
CHINESE OFFICIALS ABOUT THIS
FOR THE LAST 15 YEARS.
THEY HAVE SORT OF SLOUGHED
OFF THE WARNINGS BUT, YOU
KNOW, A COUPLE YEARS AGO
THEY REALLY STARTED TO SEAT
CONSEQUENCES OF DECLINING
DEMOGRAPHY.
>> Tucker: I HAVE BEEN
HEARING FROM DEMOCRATS IN
THIS COUNTRY WHO ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT HAVING ANY
KIDS BECAUSE OF GLOBAL
WARMING.
IT SOUNDS LIKE THE CHINESE
AREN'T AS CONCERNED ABOUT
GLOBAL WARMING AS WE ARE.
>> NO.
AND LARGELY BECAUSE EVERY
SOCIAL PROBLEM, EVERY
ECONOMIC PROBLEM THEY HAVE
ALMOST ALL OF THEM ARE MADE
WORSE BY DECLINING
DEMOGRAPHY.
AND THE CHINESE LEADERS
START TO NOTICE.
THAT'S STARTING WITH THEIR
ECONOMY.
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THEY GREW
DURING WHAT WAS CALLED THE
DEMOGRAPHIC DIVIDEND YEARS.
THAT WAS EXPANDING
WORKFORCE.
NOW THE WORKFORCE SINCE 2011
HAS STARTED TO GET SMALLER
AND IT'S GOTTEN SMALLER
FAST.
>> Tucker: SO WE HAVE THE
SAME DEMOGRAPHIC PROBLEMS
HERE, OBVIOUSLY AND SO DOES
WESTERN EUROPE DECLINING
BELOW REPLACEMENT RATE.
WE JUST IMPORT NEW PEOPLE
FROM THE DEVELOPING WORLD.
HAS IT OCCURRED TO THE
CHINESE TO DO THAT?
>> NO.
THE CHINESE DON'T WANT TO DO
THAT BECAUSE THEY HAVE A
SYSTEM AND THEN BASICALLY
IT'S BASED ON RACIAL
SUPERIORITY.
THEY DO VIEW THE REST OF THE
WORLD IN INFERIOR TERMS.
TUCKER ON ITEM MOCKOGRAPHY
WITHIN MAYBE THREE YEARS FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 300 YEARS
MAYBE ALL OF RECORDED
HISTORY CHINA IS THOUGHT
GOING TO BE THE WORLD'S MOST
POPULIST SOCIETY.
THE WORLD'S MOST POPULIST
SOCIETY WILL BE INDIA AND
THE CHINESE BOTH DISDAIN THE
INDIANS BECAUSE OF RACIAL
SUPERIORITY VIEW AND ALSO
FEAR INDIA.
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED THAT
CHINA IS SEEING A CLOSING
WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY AND
WILL LASH OUT ON THAT
HIMALAYAN BORDER.
>> Tucker: SO, VERY QUICK,
YOU JUST SAID SOMETHING THAT
ALMOST NOBODY EVER SAYS
WHICH IS THAT CHINA MAY BE
THE MOST RACIST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD MAYBE AFTER NORTH
KOREA BUT CERTAINLY RIGHT UP
THERE.
THE COUNTRY IS BASED ON
RACIAL SUPERIORITY AND YET
LIBERALS IN THIS COUNTRY
SUCK UP TO CHINA CONSTANTLY.
WHY DOES NO ONE EVER POINT
THAT OUT?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT, TO ME, IS
A MYSTERY.
THIS NATION OF ENHANCED
SUPERIORITY IS BRED INTO THE
CHINESE POLITICAL SYSTEM AND
YOU SEE IT, FOR INSTANCE,
THEY PUT ON A SKIT ON THE
CHINA CENTRAL TELEVISION'S
PROGRAM 900 MILLION PEOPLE
SAW IT THAT DEPICTED
AFRICANS AS PRIMATES.
AND IT IS IT IS JUST
INCREDIBLE, TUCKER.